To optimize the CSSOM construction we want to remove
unnecessary styles, minify, compress and cache it. Is that right?
>> Yep, those are all good ones, but if I remember correctly, I think when you
run PHP on your site it also recommended that we look in to render blocking CSS.
>> Oh yeah. What's that about?
>> Well, let's take a look. Let's say we have
a simple page with one CSS file. The browser downloads
the HTML, and then this covers and fetches the CSS. What is
the earliest point where the browser could paint the page? Is it
a, once the browser has built a DOM? Or ist it B,
once the Browser has downloaded the CSS and built the CSS object model?